hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sightline the game where
things are not always as they seem and
if you look away they might just change
for the worse or better I have no idea
but either way let's get started
whatever the hell they a button is I'm
gonna press that and we're gonna okay
anything could oh hi now this isn't a
horror game but this is actually a
pretty interesting thing the basic
concept is that thank you as you're
looking around things are gonna change
and that is so weird with all the
sparkly particles in my face and I am
rather smooth those are something behind
me and do I have boobs Zelan oh my
goodness why am i undulating so
fervently it is awfully difficult to
talk while my head is all the way down
there but anyway this should make sure
that I don't break anything and continue
on my oh my is that some sort of psycho
ballerina construct tower that I need to
be afraid of probably not I gotta say
this looks pretty cool don't know what's
going on when things are gonna get weird
yeah like that one down there that I was
just next to the one that down there an
unfallen or fallin fallin unfold that's
awfully nice but uh what about that
what's going on what am I supposed to do
why am I going up into the ballerinas
skirt is this even really a ballerina at
all I think that oh oh look okay
Jesus Birds in my face am I gonna get a
play as a bird that would be a cool
oculus rift game to play is a burden
have the birds perspective home or doubt
all over the place retain to observe the
world
you closed okay look for anything that
might receive father okay that branch is
twitching awfully ominously there's a
bunch of giant horse pills that you're
supposed to jump wait a minute hey oh oh
I see how this is what weight of it
what's going on here what ha hoo there
why sure wha what happened sorry
everybody
oh I'm just gonna Anjali for a bit here
no one saw a thing everything went
according to plan
it's backwards oh boy
markiplier is not very professional okay
and we're back and I just happen to get
some hair sweat on my lens in here so
it's kind of difficult to see but anyway
continuing on so I need to look for
something that's gonna help me proceed
but I do put wood a you know how
hello mr. blue wait a minute will you
you aren't changing where are you oh you
were oh I see how about you okay I got
Chuck oh hello
hey old yeah white oh god it's a
symphony of Psych war I did something I
think I activated the ballerina I'm just
gonna undulate in celebration for a
little bit where am I going why am I
going what happened to that thing what
is that out there is that a halo do I
need to blow that up
do I need to blow that oh that seems to
be a common theme in my life blow things
and people blow up things that people
care about
oh I see how this is uh red light or
green light right like we're like right
second oh not looking even for just
breathe
ha ha okay cool
not looking look if you're not looking
okay there's a pretty bridge
wibbly-wobbly a lovely wibbly-wobbly my
body seems a little wibbly-wobbly
I love wibbly-wobbly whoa wibbly-wobbly
is my favorite so uh okay look at these
oh do you really rounded can you uh
could you wibble something to silver all
it's a women goodness that wibbled so
good my word I need to make sure that
I'm still looking forward y'all got it
swiveling too violently just like me
that's my problem with the ladies god
that bird flew right into me hey think I
wiggle with just a little too violently
if you know what I mean yeah you wiggle
on over there and then I'm gonna
wibblewobble on you very scarily I would
hate to be on this in real life
good thing the oculus rift in real life
it's better than real life in my opinion
everything is better than real life real
life it's boring I would love to be in a
video game now by the way there was some
news okay oh you startled me for weeks
can you stop my gosh well no no I broke
everything
I broke think oh okay I didn't break
everything I thought I broke the game
for a second there pardon me if you
could wibble just a little less
violently that's a problem that I have
everything's just too much anyway as you
may have heard there was some news in
the news recently where Facebook of all
companies bought oculus rift basically
they bought the company that produce it
now what that means I have no idea the
oculus rift is a really cool device that
really opened a lot of new doors for the
world of virtual reality and all that
and why Facebook would want that of all
things I have no idea like there was
just recently um Oh what no no Whittle
over here I was almost wore cool
that's a little too much wibble there
you need to wibblewobble a little less
anyway so not of big names just joined
oculus and and obviously they bought
them for two billion dollars so oh hey
you're on so go and they ball god you
son of a [ __ ] oh my goodness they
bought them for chuni are you a yes i oh
okay am I on fire now is this where I
die okay all right
hello I'm supposed to be looking around
but for what I don't know so anyway two
billion dollars went into the purchasing
of oculus rift now that doesn't mean
that oculus isn't gonna be made anymore
it's still gonna be made what is doing
oh hey oh no please get a good good
I'm not all what what look oh my god
that's terrifying oh this game is
awesome and keep wanting to talk about
other things oh my god this is so cool
jeez this is awesome
yeah hello
okay I don't think I want to there seems
to be a lot of dastardly things going on
oh oh wait a minute
everything is fleeting sometimes
interrupting your line of sight can make
your goal disappear right in front of
your nose really tell me more about how
it's right in front of my nose
wait what a minute what a minute now
wait a minute what a minute
what a minute wait a minute what a
minute whoa don't you do it hey hey wait
a minute but if you find the right spot
to observe your destination
Oh gain better understanding of
horrifying nature ah oh oh I see oh oh
how can it be true how can it really be
possible I see what you mean because
it's right here in front of me Oh
ah come on baby
if I don't lose sight of it damn it damn
let all the hell what am I supposed to
do what am I supposed to do what about
over there
hey what what grip grip grip grip yep
Baga
where's we here wha what what is one of
these times that's gonna turn into
Slenderman I'm on of a just totally
boned in every way say so I got to make
that stay somehow ah ha ha ha ha wait a
minute what am i no ha ha
now whoa yeah buddy
hey half-life wrong side sorry you
douche
got it all right okay okay okay all
right all right all right all right all
right all right what's cooler than being
cool things don't quite look as you
expected at first glance no okay I'm
glancing damn it pissing potatoes I got
stool bone to pick with ill oh wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute oh oh I see
there's more than one ah ha ha ha ha ha
ha gotcha Oh what the hell no no no no
no no it was who's there
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
isn't now this is gone ok ok so now
that's gone and I need to go over there
that's where I can't be looking at it
when I go over yeah yeah even the oh
yeah I got you I got you I got you
I'm getting you whoa Gold hell yeah I
want some of that
okay today three to six pm got it
you look what what what what what what
what what what ask enough for me
yeah buddy all right oh hello Oh Oh
means it escaped wait a minute you like
whoa okay see slicing at you wait a
minute what you look now uh-huh
no it was a shovel it was a shovel okay
but then in the face of danger with no
means of escape uh-huh uh-huh see spike
subdued and puzzling at you you look
down and see a deadly okay okay okay can
change now oh good again find the slacks
reasonable breeze okay and find that the
pitch was never really that okay okay
I'm confused I'm very very very confused
no idea what's happening what does that
say what does that say still wrong way
okay oh come on
Oh Oh being in T place close oh oh oh oh
he changes his mind
Oh still wrong way but come closer okay
oh come on oh oh my good god this is so
weird
often things can seem different yeah oh
yeah oh oh I didn't have boobs I just
said you eivol god that is weird
hi buddy how you doing friend you doing
good you look good
very undulation ewwww I love it
so uh so what all dot you're in my oh
hello ah yes
cool Oh God
whoa what is that whoa what is that no
no no no oh geez you murderous bastard
good lordy Lou okay oh god okay don't
look whoa what huh he's gone now
what happened did I make it I don't know
the things change when you don't himself
yeah sometimes just sometimes
you have to keep looking and they'll
change right in front of your eyes okay
if you say so so there's a mirror up
there am I supposed to be looking at
that I'm not sure oh oh okay
ah oh wow cool and stop got it do they
get all hello squiggly douches okay whoa
wait a minute
oh I got some there need to keep looking
at I need to keep looking at I just got
a go dude stop
is it done did it finish what okay hey
cool god damn that was awesome oh man
that was mine bedding bending good lordy
loo that was amazing it was awesome
those most original thing I've seen in a
long time that didn't even you know what
was honest I don't even think that
really needed the oculus rift you could
have done that without it that was
really cool man that was cool oh wow I
could really use a good graphics guy
anyway it wasn't bad a lot of it was
stock stuff but anyway that's really
awesome anyway this game was called
sight line and it's currently on
Kickstarter IndieGoGo there will be a
link in the description below and this
information here but that was really
really cool I liked that a lot
man that was totally aa-men god if
you've messed with my face my head haha
either way it was just really really
really awesome whoo
goodness gracious that was pretty dang
awesome guys thank you guys so much for
watching um hi recapping a few things
the games on Kickstarter you can find
the link in the description below
also if you got an opinion or something
you want to talk about I didn't get a
chance to talk about it kind of so
involved in the game there but Facebook
did buy oculus rift if you got
information or an opinion on what you
think of the future that is right in the
comments below I want to hear what you
guys think about that because I really
think that the oculus have a great
device but I don't know what this means
for the future but anyway if you enjoyed
this video please let me know in the
comments below leave a like if you did
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos it I've
done and as always I will see
you in the next video by taking my time
put some bars on doors that may be
unnecessary or maybe